[Music]
michael is with us in las vegas hey
michael what's up
hey how are you doing dave better than i
deserve how can i help
hey so um i've never had any like
financial teachings except for like
youtube and that's where i found you um
i owe 280 000 on my house
and i had 50 grand in the bank and i was
wondering should i just put that 50
right toward the principal or put it in
the market and once it reaches my house
payoff
then pull it out and pay off my house
do you have any other debt
no
do you have any other savings
i have uh i have 50 000 in my
uh deferred comp retirement thing but i
can't pull it out
until i'm
retired
well first of all way to go on being
debt free
that's awesome you're in a great
position
you do want to have an emergency fund
you want to have a fully funded
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses so i don't know what that would
be for you but you want to make sure you
set that aside and that's going to be in
cash in a savings account that you can
access anytime it doesn't need to be
invested it doesn't need to be
complicated
and you don't want to put that towards
the house because you need to access it
if something goes wrong but then the
rest what you're going to do is if
if you're not already investing on baby
step number four you want to invest 15
um on baby step number four and then you
wanna take the rest and just put it
towards uh put it towards your house and
uh and drop that down you shouldn't have
any type of fees or penalties for paying
a larger sum at one time and that will
drop your uh drop your balance down and
you're just making progress uh at the
same time
maybe step six so michael the deal is
this um
i i'm honored that you found us on
youtube
um
it uh
scares me that that's your only source
of information
um and i don't think we we lack
credibility we do we do this for a
living but you probably need to get some
books and uh some other things i'll send
you a copy of our best-selling book the
total money makeover which will walk you
through the whole process
process of building wealth and
christie's exactly on track there
we teach a process
that literally tens of millions of
people have done called the baby steps
which is the shortest distance between
where you are in wealth
which was the underlying question you
asked what's the fastest way for me to
get wealthy
meaning pay off my house have some money
is it put the money in the stock market
or does it pay off my house with the
money so you need an emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses as she
outlined and you put the rest of it on
the mortgage the reason we say to do
that rather than invest the difference
is that um
the data that we have having studied 10
000 millionaires
among those
that became millionaires uh
north of 80 of them
did so by two primary things which is
most of them in other words
they got a they got their home paid off
and that was a big chunk of their net
worth and they steadily invested into
their retirement accounts whether it's
deferred comp 401k
roth iras something along those lines
but usually it was 401ks and roth iras
deferred comps usually down the list
so um
you know that's what i would have you to
do is let's work to get the house paid
off and then when that's paid off not
having a house payment enables you to
invest a lot of money per month
and the
advantage is that you're able to build
wealth very very quickly then